aquí hay quien habla de una débil
defensa por parte de la casa blanca en
este viaje de nancy pelosi a taiwán al
parecer y según ha revelado un alto
funcionario de washington el presidente
estadounidense y nancy pelosi no habrían
hablado antes de este viaje y tampoco
está previsto que lo hagan hemos
escuchado al portavoz del consejo de
seguridad nacional de eeuu john kirby
quien ha dicho que este viaje de nancy
pelosi a taiwán es congruente va de
acuerdo con la forma de tratar este caso
de la isla de taiwán por parte de
washington ha dicho que no tendría por
qué suponer ninguna crisis política para
de quien también la embajadora de eeuu
ex embajadora de eeuu ante las naciones
unidas ha dicho que la pataleta la
rabieta de china no va a conducir la
política exterior la política
internacional de eeuu así mismo también
el líder de la minoría en el senado
mitch mcconnell 24 25 senadores más ha
firmado un comunicado en el que
mostraban su apoyo
viaje a taiwán también hemos podido leer
un artículo de opinión que la misma
nancy pelosi escribió para el washington
post y que se ha publicado justo después
de que ella aterrizará en la isla en el
que pelosi defiende este viaje dice que
es un símbolo de su apoyo del apoyo de
eeuu a la democracia el apoyo a un socio
democrático como estay de taiwan aquí
todos los medios de comunicación van con
el mismo titular pero si hace oídos
sordos a esas advertencias furiosas de
china y parece que da la sensación de
que preparan a la población para unas
consecuencias para una escalada de la
tensión entre las dos principales
potencias políticas a raíz de esta
visita